today I met with Prime Minister Boris
Johnson by videoconference to take stock
of progress with the aim of agreeing
actions to move forward in negotiations
on the future relationship alongside
with President of the European
Parliament David Sasori and the
President of the European Council shall
Michel we noted the UK's decision not to
request any extension to the transition
period the transition period will
therefore end on the 31st of December
2020 in line with the provisions of the
withdrawal agreement we welcomed the
constructive discussions on the future
relationship that had taken place under
the leadership of chief negotiators
David Frost and Michel Barnier allowing
both sides to clarify and further
understand positions for rounds have
been completed and text exchanged
despite the challenges presented by the
covett 19 pandemic we agreed
nevertheless that new momentum was
required we supported the plans agreed
by chief negotiators to intensify the
talks in July and to create the most
conducive conditions for concluding and
ratifying a deal before the end of 2020
this should include if possible finding
an early understanding on the principles
underlying any agreement we underlined
our intention to work hard to deliver a
relationship which would work in the
interests of the citizens of the Union
and of the United Kingdom we also
confirmed our commitment to the full and
timely implementation of the withdrawal
agreement